the day before the press conference that
we discussed last segment
cal mcnair the owner of the texans in a
letter to season ticket holders said
that
the texans are taking the situation
very seriously as reported hpd in the
national football league are conducting
investigations we will cooperate fully
we respect the legal process we will
continue to monitor the situation
closely that was before yesterday's
press conference
it just occurred to me we haven't heard
from the texans since yesterday's press
conference maybe they will have
something to say especially since now
they're
sort of indirectly being implicated we
talked about that last segment the idea
that
that busby said at some point you have
an obligation to ask questions
and something doesn't add up chris if
you have this
world-class facility with massage
therapists on salary
and this guy is asking for referrals for
massage therapists and asking to borrow
tables for massages that are going to be
occurring
off-site something doesn't add up and
the argument will be
if busby pursues this
did the texans know something they
should have known did they fail to do
something they should have done
and are the texans responsible here but
i look the texans chris
uh they already had a problem with
deshaun watson now they've got a problem
and i don't think any teams ever had to
deal with to this extent i don't think
so right
and and uh i i don't i don't know what
they i don't know what they do i don't
know what you can do
at this point if you're the houston
texans i don't think there's much they
can do i mean they just got to kind of
sit back
and and and kind of let this all play
out now
i do i think it's out of their hands you
know and again listen
i can understand them asking for a
player asking a team for referrals
or borrowing a massage table all right i
all that that happens but like
two or three times or i've kept that
same table for a long time
or okay two or three times and now i
found the right
masseuse and i'm sticking with them
because they know how to work my body or
do those things
i mean again that's what's weird these
are athletes who are obsessed with their
body
they know exactly how they feel i like
this
masseuse because she she or he
understands
my job where i get sore you know where
my tendencies are to always kind of
flare up whatever that may be
that in itself is fishy there's no doubt
about that i mean i'm not going to say
that it's
you know again players do ask for
referrals and get massage tables but
you know if this was commonplace then
yeah you wonder why the texans wouldn't
have
maybe asked like what the hell is going
on why haven't you found one you really
like what what
is the issue there the nfl issued a
statement after yesterday's press
conference the allegations are deeply
disturbing and we take these issues very
seriously immediately following the news
of the first allegations last month
and has been reported we initiated an
investigation under the nfl's personal
conduct policy
we are continuing to closely monitor all
developments in the matter
chris as i said earlier i think they
have to put them on the commissioner
exempt list at this point
i don't think you can do what they've
done in the past and i've had these
discussions with people from the league
office
why are you not doing anything someone's
been arrested someone's been charged
with
whatever well it's the off season
there's really nothing to keep them from
like
there's no need to make it this is my
interpretation yeah
no need to make it a bigger story than
it is
by putting him on the commissioner
exempt list because then we buy another
news cycle
where everyone's talking about desean
watts no reason to do it what do we gain
he's not
on a football field anyway he's not
being televised by our network partners
people aren't in the awkward position of
having to talk about him so there's
nothing to do
at some point there is there is to do is
the right thing right you got to stand
up and you got to say
this doesn't fly he's on the
commissioner exempt list
until further notice period i i feel
like they're at the point where they
have to do that i
agreed i mean i just think yeah you know
they're going to lose in the court of
public opinion and seem insensitive
if they don't do that here soon you know
again
here's the big question with desean
watson all right i mean
he's gonna get suspended i would be
shocked i mean we
i mean that that seems like inevitable
at this point
all right how many games i don't know
here's my big question
i mean is he ever gonna play football
again
i i think that's legitimate like
question right now
in our like with what we've seen now
that was one person
we had a you know a public statement for
it from yesterday
at least you know in person to see the
face and all that
you know if we continue to get a few
more to go along with it
wow but i just wonder
like okay how long does this litigation
process take
you know like you said it could take a
long long time so that could be
all right we've lost the year of
football just because he's on the
commissioner exempt
list and we're trying to figure out you
know the the
the system and how it goes that way the
the case itself
so you have that aspect but then like
mike i mean
as that case goes on of course more
dirty laundry is going to be aired it's
not going to look good for desean watson
and then here we are in 2021 with the
current current climate and those type
of things
i am i'm on the i'm not sure we're going
to see desean watson play football again
i think we're getting into that
territory you're onto something here and
we're getting short on time but i want
to make this point
yeah if he continues to fight and fight
and fight and fight it's going to
continue to go poorly and poorly and
poorly and poorly at some point you've
got to accept this
if you've got to understand where this
is going and if he does fight it all the
way through and if a prosecution
does ultimately start and if there is
enough evidence to convince a jury
beyond a reasonable doubt that he
violated the laws he may not be able to
play football or do anything else for a
period of years
and years and and and and here's the
comparison i want to make
mike vick even though it was completely
different factual setting he denied he
denied he denied and then he finally
realized he was boxed in and there was
only one thing to do and he pleaded
guilty
and he any and he paid his debt to
society and he was back in the nfl on
the back end
at some point you've got to acknowledge
that it's over and that you've lost and
that's the hard conversation
that someone needs to have with deshaun
watson because if you fight this
tooth and nail is going to cost you a
ton of money it's going to derail your
career and it may put you behind bars
for a very long time if you refuse to
acknowledge
what you did hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports